صفقات كبيرة أجندات كبيرة حدث سنوي
للحديث عن الابتكار والتكنولوجيا لتحفيز
النمو وبدأت الإمارات العربية المتحدة
بأكبر سوقين ناشئين
، ليس من السهل القيام بهذا
المشروع وفقًا لرئيس
إحدى أكبر التكتلات في الخليج التي تعمل على
تكسير الصين  كان معلمًا رئيسيًا
قبلونا كشركاء معهم في
الأعمال التجارية وهم يقدرون جودتنا ويقدرون دفاعنا
لأن الشفافية والأعمال التجارية هي
أهم التجارة بين
الصين والإمارات ومن المتوقع أن تصل إلى سبعين
مليار دولار بحلول عام 2020 ومع
الهند.  من المتوقع أن تتجاوز 100 مليار
دولار في نفس الإطار الزمني لمتابعة
مشاريع في تجارة الطاقة
والبنية التحتية ، بدأ كل ذلك في عام 2008
عندما زار رئيس وزراء دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة
وحاكم دبي الشيخ محمد بن راشد آل
مكتوم الصين تلاه بعد سبع
سنوات ولي عهد أبو
أبوظبي لتعزيز العلاقات لا تزال تؤتي
ثمارها ، تفتتح شركة الشحن الصينية العملاقة
كوستكو منطقة جديدة  إنفاق أكثر من
300 مليون دولار في المنطقة الصناعية بأبو ظبي ،
وكل ذلك جزء من
مبادرة الحزام والطريق الطموحة ،
كانت الهند محور تركيز القمة الحكومية العالمية العام الماضي ، حيث
تم عقد صفقات كبيرة
بما في ذلك عمالقة النفط الحكوميون الذين أضافوا
nock واستثمار أرامكو السعودية 44
مليار دولار في  مصفاة في الهند
جزء من استراتيجية أوسع بين الإمارات العربية المتحدة
والمملكة العربية السعودية للنفط والغاز
وحقيقة أننا نتعاون معًا في
تكامل بعضنا البعض بناءً على
نقاط قوتهم ومن ثم البناء على
نقاط قوتنا سيسمح لنا بأن نكون
أكثر خبرة.  خدمة تقديم الطعام
لتلبية متطلبات الطاقة العالمية ،
تعد الإمارات العربية المتحدة موطنًا لأقل من
10 ملايين شخص وتركز بشكل واضح
على تسخير النمو والاستثمار
في أكبر سوقين ناشئين في العالم
John dev tereus CNN business
Dubai